morning everyone it's my great pleasure
to be introducing uh a young voltage
for let's okay thank you very much
um on the second day uh welcome back to
everyone uh Jan is going to be talking
about common graphs with large chromatic
number please go ahead John okay uh
thank you very much for the introduction
also I would like to thank the
organizers for uh inviting me and giving
me the opportunities
speak here so all I'm gonna talk about
today is a joint work with Dan Krall uh
yeah and also uh he's from masary
University in Czech Republic and with
fun ways
so okay
before before I move on to the problem
that will bother me and perhaps bother
you for the next 45 minutes uh let me
start with some combinatorial motivation
for this type of problems and
to go really back to the beginning uh a
classical result is
Ramsay theory is that R3 equals six uh
what does it mean it means that if you
take any red blue coloring of the
complete graph on six vertices you have
no way to avoid uh seeing a
monochromatic triangle
so okay and if you give me a click that
is larger than six and you write blue
color as well I can forget n minus six
vertices of it and still find one
monochromatic triangle but uh and okay
so far I guess I've said only one
inequality of this R3 equal to six also
there is a five vertex ground there is a
coloring of a five vertex concrete graph
that has no monochromatic triangle so
this six is in a way best possible but
uh if you give me a large complete graph
perhaps uh
we now know that you see at least one
monoharmatic triangle as a matter of
fact already on those six uh if you red
blue color k6 you see at least two
monochromatic triangles not only one uh
but uh if the graph you are coloring is
large you
it sounds natural to find money many
more copies many more monochromatic
triangles not just one or two uh and
indeed that's true because I'm like one
way of observing it is that if you look
at any window of size six by Ramsay
theorem you see at least one well now we
know at least two uh monochromatic
triangles uh and if you move this window
all over all over the place
uh just by averaging argument you see
roughly at least n Cube over 20
monochromatic triangles so one remark I
want to make right away is that when I'm
counting subgraphs I'm counting labeled
copies so to some extent every
monochromatic triangle
gives me plus six to my account because
there is six ways how to label its
vertices for triangles it's perhaps
rather an odd way of counting it with
perhaps something more natural if I just
don't interve this artificial factor of
six uh soon we will be counting
monochromatic copies of graphs that are
much less symmetric so in this labeled
way it will perhaps make my life easier
to not care that much of the automorph
of the size and structure of the
automorphism groups
I will be counting labeled copies during
the whole talk
so but even this this argument that just
moves this window and applies around
this year I mean each of it in each of
these windows uh sounds like a little
bit wasteful and it doesn't seem like
this is the this is the best way how to
count and indeed that's true and uh for
counting monochromatic triangles there
is a result uh that is an old result
from late 50s of Goodman which says that
actually in any red blue coloring of KN
you see roughly at least n Cube over
four monochromatic triangles
uh and this result so and and it's known
that uh this is the best possible uh I
believe that this form is actually best
possible for everyone
so okay so what about other graphs H
than just triangle and
the game you would like to play is again
that we consider arbitrary red blue
coloring of the edges of KN uh so Ramses
drm4 is not something special for
triangle it applies to every age so for
every age there is some number six well
different than six uh that uh you see at
least one copy one monochromatic copy no
matter how you write blue color of the
edges and now if you take this as the
the Ramsay Number for H as the size of
your window and you move it all over the
place in a much larger complete graph
again in each of these windows you find
at least one copy you average this
through and you get that uh you always
see some positive fraction of the total
number of copies you can even hope for
because if your graph age has some
number of vertices okay you certainly
cannot find more than m to the K copies
foreign
so again this gives some positive
fraction but it sounds like this should
not be I mean this is perhaps not
optimal for this is perhaps wasteful for
every graph age maybe apart for some
trivialities uh
so uh
the theme or the question is how much
better can one do
so
for this uh let me count the number of
copies in J simply as the number of
homomorphisms from VH to VG
oh
so uh and then what's the monoharomatic
count in a red blue coloring of a
complete graph is just the number in the
red graph number of copies in the red
graph plus the number of copies in the
blue graph normalized by the total
number of maps
uh
so
in
rephrasing The Goodman's theorem in this
uh in this language uh it says that for
every red blue coloring the mono count
of triangles is at least one quarter
uh which also I mean one way of
realizing that uh module or lower order
terms this one converter is best
possible is that uh
you just take a random red blue coloring
well then if the red blue coloring of
your complete graph was random then
roughly 80 1 8 of your copies are
monochromatic in red one eight uh
of the copies are monochromatic in blue
so yeah certainly one cannot hope to
improve this one quarter just using this
simple observation
uh all right so since this is a workshop
on graph limit actually let me
reformulate this uh
let me reformulate the the good month
result
once again uh
and uh
uh at least to me uh using the using the
graph limits or graph Graphics notation
is actually much more convenient in uh
for for this uh for this topic and
and it will be the theme for for the
whole Target uh uh one perhaps doesn't
appear or any does not necessarily mean
need the graph on language but it will
make uh the questions and also uh the
result much uh much easier to approach
if one uses the the
notion of Graphics so anyways so what
does what does uh good months how one
can rephrase good months uh in
equivalent it's a result of Goodman to
the language of graphones if you give me
so whatever would be like the analog of
red blue coloring of a complete graph
well you can always think that red is my
graph and blue is just the complement so
and
and instead of saying graph I will take
red as my graphone and blue as my as the
complement of microphone which is simply
one minus w
so it says that the that the T of uh the
number of triangles in W plus the number
of triangles in one minus W is at least
two times uh the number of triangles in
one in constant one half which is the
graphene analog of the density one half
so in particle it's at least one
and uh I will call a graph comma I will
call a graph H common if it is like
triangle in this sense uh and what do I
mean by that for every graphone W the H
count in W plus the H count in one minus
W is at least as the graphons
and indeed and of course if the graph
one was the constant one half then the
number of copies is just two to minus
number of edges of H because for each of
them I need to get the correct hats on
mine as the outcome of my coin
so what graphs are common apart from
triangle there was a conjecture in 60s
that every concrete graph is a common
graph and then
maybe every graph age is actually common
so
uh these are the two conjectures and
well we now know that both of them uh
are uh
are wrong actually uh
the the conjecture of f Dash starts
being wrong as soon as K is at least
four so apart from H which would be
which is common for trivialization
triangle there is no other complete
graph that is common
question you are talking about grass
phonographs and then you go to the
graphics whatever then you talk about
the densities the density
uh
eventually the graphite isn't quite the
same as density in finite graphs it
there's an error about 100 right right
uh but you are also talking about finite
graph so I'm having a little trouble
ah yeah so so daylight so uh the way how
I Define it in the stock I Define what a
common graph means only when we talk
about graph phones so of course the
notion predates graphons and then the
original definition was actually saying
it's awesome I mean it will be a
statement about us where about the
sequence of graphs okay yeah so so this
is really an equivalent statement and I
I perhaps wanted to save my time to
State the original definition using
graphs but the small graph that plays
game here it will always be some fixed
finite graph
yeah that was kind of uh what I was
trying to hit that using graphones makes
stating and also working with this much
easier but a priority it's not needed
yes
so uh so no click is coming apart from H
and triangle uh and also so in
particular bura and rosta cannot hold
but around the same time as Thomason
disproved the conjecture of sidorenko
found an easier argument by triangle
with the pendant H is not a common graph
so and then uh
a few years later it was actually shown
that as long as your small graph H
contains K4
that's a reason why H is not a common
graph so statistically speaking almost
no graph is common
a typical graph H does contain K4
so uh Now sort of
after seeing this it's now a question
like okay so any other non-trivial grass
apart from a triangle that are common
well there are
uh
some some of the examples of common
graphs are Cycles or even Wheels which
is a cycle within with a universal
vertex attached to all its vertices uh
sidorenco graphs I know come to this uh
in a minute what I mean by that uh and
as one more prominent example of a of a
gravitism graph H that is known to be
common is it's the five wheel
uh
okay so maybe before I go any further uh
let me pause here and check if there are
any questions
oh it's a complete
what was the reason for air conditioner
Rockstar to to conjecture
you know it's pretty dates my birthday
so it's sort of hard for me to try to
guess
[Music]
once you know
so
but I
the way how we
like I said it's hard for me to come
about indeed you are either to some
extent those projects cannot be more
wrong than they are
so one reason might be the diagonal
ramps the number so Thomas
number I mean the ideal problems relies
on Goodman's formula so it was kind of
natural to expect
um such a thing also holds for a general
um complete graph which would then allow
us to improve thomason's thought
but that suggests that it's impossible
okay thank you
oh
so
so okay so I was saying cedarenkograph
so actually let me now move a little bit
uh say a little bit about what what I
mean by that so the graph is called
graph H is called sidorenko and again
let me just state it using the the
notion of like the limit notion Define
it only using graphons
but that would be also uh an analogous
definition for Segment where instead of
w I would consider some sequence of
graphs here uh so I call graph sidorenko
if graph H C dorenko if it's count in
any graph from W is at least as large as
if I replace W with a random gravity
with the appropriate density
uh
in other words like among all graphs all
graphones that have density p uh the way
how to minimize the the H count uh is to
take the random it's to take the
constant function p
so couple of observations if your graph
is sidorenko then it's common because uh
to some extent uh if you want to show
that a graph is common you need to you
need to uh lower bound the count in a
red and blue and if your graph is
sidorenko just by convexity you have a
good handle on both inner red and both
in blue so
so you are in a good shape also if some
graph H should have a chance to be
sidorenko it near it necessarily needs
to be bipartite as long as you give me a
graph age that is non bipartite for
example I can take the complete
bipartite graphene with any non-trivial
density like one half for example uh the
H count there for chromatic reasons is
zero there but it so it certainly loses
against the random ground
so and as a remark all known bipartite
all known graphs age that are bipartite
and proven to be common are also known
to be sidorenko
and uh famous conjecture of sidorenko is
that whether this whether
let me use the pointer for
online people but this implication can
actually be reversed
uh so what is known on what is known on
sidorenko's conjecture well it has been
proven for various classes of bipartite
graphs like three Cycles complete
bipartite graphs hyper tubes and more uh
uh and and here I just uh listed set of
people who are behind all of these uh
all of these results and and and more of
these more on the results on this uh top
but in general it is still widely open
conjecture and the smallest open graph
age where we don't know is if you take
this mebius leather or in other words
you take complete bipartite graph with
parts of size five and you remove the
Hamilton cycle
uh
so
that's about
the sidorenkos conjecture but uh
again uh
one doesn't need a priori graph limits
but uh
uh having graph limits as a tool was uh
was uh was very handy when uh but try to
look at uh sort of a weaker version of a
relaxation of the of sidorenko's
conjecture and and the sit and the the
relaxation I have now in my mind is uh
is the local version of it so in
sidorenko we are trying to compare the H
count uh uh
okay
yeah we are wondering whether the
constant graphone is a global minimizer
of age count among all graphones with a
given density so in the local version
well we just we don't go through
all the graph forms w
but only uh we take the minimum overdose
that are close that are close to the
constant function p and ask is it the
case that H is minimized in this ball uh
by the constant function p
and the the distance I have in mind is
on graphones is is the cut distance
so uh okay so this perhaps sounds like
uh the natural uh
the natural local variant of the
conjecture well in the actual definition
of localized there is some additional
technical assumption on the L infinitino
uh
streets a little bit further the the
graphones that the graph are minimizing
over
anyways uh extending the result of of
lovers Fox anyway showed that graph H so
it seems like that okay it seems that
that is an there is a nice conjecture
characterizing sidorenko's graph but it
also seems that we are very far from
understanding it well in the local
direction we actually do we do have a
full understanding uh it was proven a
few years ago that uh graph H is local
acidorenko exactly when the girth of age
is even and by guard I mean the length
of the shortest cycle image
uh okay
so
before I go any further
any questions
what is a k55
it's a complete
it's a complete bipartite graph
foreign
crops which are known to be common
that's exactly on my next slide
uh okay uh actually on my next slide I'm
already skipping the circuit yeah okay
anyways that's a good question and yeah
let me talk about it so as as you just
recalled triangle is known to be common
but uh
not only a triangle you can also glue
triangles along edges or glue triangles
along the vertices and uh
again you can show that like if you
basically build up any tree that is
consisting of of triangles glued along
edges or glued along but this is it will
also give you a common graph uh also I
think that on the previous slide sorry
on the on the two slides back I said
that all even wheels are common so an
even cycle with a universal vertex
attached to everybody so that gives a
class of many graphs that have chromatic
number three and are also common
but for quite a while uh
and sort of kind of coming from The
Other Extreme once uh and Thomas and
realize that uh containing a K4 is a
good reason for H to not be common maybe
already a chromatic number is a good
reason to not be common
uh so in particular they ask is there
any common graph with chromatic number
higher density that is common
okay
uh an imp and like the the usual suspect
sort of the smallest
non-city chromatic uh
graph age that is not containing K4
would be the five wheel so I already
spoiled it uh on my first slide to
Common graph that five deal is is known
to be common uh and it was proven
roughly 10 years ago by Hamad
Serge and rasborough and
from nowadays point of view it's a
straightforward application of the flag
algebra
psychopathically it does rely on some
computer assistance and my understanding
is that uh the flag Fleck algebra proof
is the only way how we know that the
graph is that five deal is is common
uh so then the barrier of three was
broken but
the following natural question would
would be or at least to me would be and
it was to the group of the people and
the question was again reiterated by
conlon Fox and sudakov in their survey
on on a Ramsay number
is there a common graph uh with a given
chromatic number k
so
I guess that's what my title was of the
talk was saying so the main result is uh
is answered it's a positive and the
positive answer to this question so
stating it is that for every K there is
a common graph HK that has chromatic
number equal to K
uh and how does such a graph look like
well we actually have a slightly
stronger result and and this chromatic
bound is only a corollary of it so more
or less so so our
actual results says the following you
give me any graph s and the only thing
what I want from you is that the girth
of your graph f is at least some some
small constant I put here on the slide
42 but I guess it's not the best
constant we have in the paper yeah I
like 42.
uh
so
and
that's exactly what's the logic behind
uh me putting this is last night in this
on the slot uh so
you give me this graph I can decorate it
a little bit so I will attach some short
part and a C4 uh on one side and I will
attach another path on the other side
and uh a complete bypass and place a
complete bipartite graph at the end
and the statement is that uh
just based on this graph F there is some
n0 and if the parameter is m n and L
play a little bit
play a little some some delicate game uh
uh
uh with respect to this F this
construction gives you a common graph
so I want to say some something about
the proof but uh before I go any further
let me again pause here and
ask if there are some questions maybe
you can tell us what provided number of
this construction all right uh so why
does why does this actual statement
implied uh what I promised uh well
uh
that is this uh that is another
well-known result of adesh that for any
girls G and any chromatic number K there
is a there is a graph that has girls G
and chromatic number K so now if as this
so so in particle I have candidate
graphs F that have a large chromatic
number and unbounded girl so in
particular girls larger than 42.
and if I attach something to them I will
definitely not decrease their chromatic
number
okay
foreign
can I comment on that only at the end so
so I mean
it it is sort of not important for what
I want to say in the so but yeah
let me go
to that in the
end so uh
what is the proof idea uh
well we essentially split the proven we
distinguished two cases in the proof uh
in the first case we considered that
this W and if W then also the complement
one minus W are far from the constant
graph
and uh
in if that's the case then uh actually
it's not uh
it's more or less a standard uh argument
the next demographic theory that
either
we can find uh
uh in one of the colors say in the red
one some
subset of vertices
which induces uh only a little only a
tiny number of edges and in that case we
would induct uh on S in blue and uh
and finish just by having enough copies
of age in the blue color or if we don't
find The Spar subset uh
then every vertex yeah I promise I will
not be I will be pointing with this uh
every vertex uh essentially everywhere
almost every vertex lies in some
positive number
of uh copies h
uh
and if so
and in that in in this second case the
the thing what we do is that uh okay so
on every on every vertex we we have some
we have some uh
some positive fraction of copies of H
and also uh see and so so far we haven't
used that uh uh the graphones W and one
minus W are far from return but now is
the time to use it so kmn is a sidoran
program so in particular both in a red
and in blue DC at least as many copies
of KM and s in the random s we would see
in the random one but actually in
one way of looking at it is that
inspecting to prove ykmn is 0 renko why
is it minimized at uh at the constant
function one half
or a constant function uh p uh tells you
that if you are far from this constant
function you actually get the positive
boost
and that boost we're gonna exploit uh
and
and the parameters Clash together
correctly uh to conclude that indeed in
that case we really see uh at least as
many copies of graph h s as we need to
so the main part of the argument is uh
actually lies in this in the in the
other case so namely when the graph on W
is close to the constant one half
but then at least uh if I try to
convince you in basically one or two
minutes uh well the growth of this graph
H is 4 and I told you that uh
an even girth is a good reason for graph
to be local acidorenko
so perhaps the first attempt would be to
just finish uh by using Fox anyway as a
result uh
probably today uh so unfortunately
it doesn't so we were not able to use
this box anyway as a black box for two
reasons one of them was this additional
Infinity assumption uh I mentioned in
the definition of local acidorenko but
also and
a much more substantial reason was that
uh for this interplay of the parameters
of this construction uh they sort of I
mean this plan uh in the far case and in
the closed case sort of goes against
each other so we need so uh in order to
make to make this to uh and happen
make these two uh options cover really
all possibilities of graph on W uh we
need a stronger statement we need a sort
of statement uh where uh where the
locality bound would be independent on
these parameters
but uh so the control to have completely
independent in the local in the local
system I thought that would be too much
to ask but just in this specific family
uh HK yeah we were able to
do it and
that concluded indeed that locally the H
count is minimized uh uh by the random
function so
the questions
so to conclude uh yes again the the
result which says that uh there are
common graphs with unbounded with the
with a with an arbitrary large chromatic
number
uh so coming back again
that line so a common graph is that you
arbitrary red blue color it's it's
arbitrarily red blue color the edges of
a concrete graph or split your constant
graph on one into two graphones w and
one minus W uh the Ramsay number sorry I
mean Ramses theorem that doesn't that's
not something that they would be
tailored to two colors you can also
L color the edges of the concrete graph
and once it's like once the complete
graph is large enough you see the
monochromatic copy of your favorite
graph H in at least one of the colors so
uh one can sort of play the very same
game also uh in this multi-coloration so
again let me just Define what an Alka
what what does it mean for H to be L
common using the the graphone the graph
limits language so
it says the following no matter how you
split the constant function one into
collection of algorithms
all different
for each of them I think that they
represent the graphene wi represent the
uh edges colored with uh color I uh the
monochromatic count is lower bounded
s if those algorithms would be random
functions one over l
uh
so
a couple more observations uh on this
once your graph H stop is not welcome
there is a simple extension argument
that tells that it's also not L plus one
common so uh once it stop being held
common then it's never L Prime common
for L Prime larger than L and also as
soon as your karma as soon as the
chromatic number of H is at least three
that exit you can cook up uh some
multi-color
uh
multi-color uh coloring of the complete
graph where uh you build the random one
the random coloring so so in other words
every every non-bipartal graph stops
being held common for some l0
uh but on the other hand if H is
sidorenko then the F then sort of the
convexity argument that I set for two
colors again applies also here I want a
Bound in the sum and if H is I have I
have a I have a control in every of the
colors so uh the sum is at least at
least the average
uh so uh that's an implication uh in
one of the previous works with fun and
done and also together with John Royal
and Sergey we actually show that this is
equivalent and it's equivalent
independently on sidorenco's conjecture
so I mean if Syrian cross conjecture is
true every bipartite graph uh would be
sidorenko then okay once the chromatic
number is once the H is not bipart like
this cannot hold and one if you believe
in ceteroncos conjecture then uh you
have it for a very bipartite so if
sidorenco's conjecture is true then this
equivalence is actually trivial but uh
we show this equivalence uh even
independently ones in the rainbow's
conjecture
and uh
also in in that paper we provided the
first example of a non-bipartite graph
for L at least
so the particle triangle is not three
common
uh
there are some graphs that are not
bipartite and are three common four
common and so on
so and this was sort of one of the
starting points for our uh for for the
main result I was presenting today and
uh well the natural question is whether
one can generalize this uh what I
presented here also to this
multi-colored setting and long story
short yes one catch
so uh
sort of
conclude uh
let me say a few
a few more remarks and open problems uh
in here so I guess one of the
one of the smallest example for
sidorenko's conjecture is this k55 minus
C10 so whether it's the Durango or not
that's uh
sort of one of the current questions in
uh regarding sidorenko but uh so if it
is either encode then also it should be
common so maybe it's seemingly uh an
easier problem would be to show uh that
k55 minus C10 is a common ground
but we don't know that
uh also uh
you more uh comments on on our on our
construction of this common graph or L
command gravity uh the arbitrary High
chromatic number so there are a couple
of features of this of this construction
for instance so the graph is connected
but it's not too connected
so uh actually at the end of of our
paper we asked whether one can uh have a
construction of a common graph ultimate
graph more generally that has arbitrary
High chromatic number and also arbitrary
High connectivity so it was shown by KO
and Julie who is
in the audience that uh indeed you can
also boost the connectivity to an arbit
array
and with the connectivity arbiter
so uh
that's one feature of of uh our
construction that turns out to be not
necessary another uh
feature of this construction is that the
girls the length of the shortest cycle
in all of our graphs is for because of
the C4 here but the C4 here is really is
really just to make the argument more
convenient yeah
uh the C4 here is is really just to make
uh some of our arguments smoother than
uh without it but there is lots of C4s
also in this other side and and that's
what we exploited the Boost the Boost in
KN
so uh
an open problem would be also an another
an open problem uh is that uh can you
also make the girls large
so
to say it precisely is there a common
graph H that has high chromatic number
High Gert and high connectivity
and I guess
it's exactly 40 minutes now so
all right thank you for this very nice
talk uh are there any questions we still
have one
yeah maybe you want to get started on
that okay sure so this this flag algebra
method uh in one sentence it's sort of
like an automatized applications of so
so lots of results in extremograph here
you can provide using caution smarts
and uh and using coffee that sort of
link to finding like some of squares
proof uh that some graph density
inequality holds so in one sentence that
says everything and on the other hand
nothing is that uh finding some
certificate for some some sum of square
certificate for an inequality that
smells like semi-definite programming
and Fleck algebra is a particular uh
particular translation of of proving
some grab density inequalities as find a
sum of squares uh
find a sum of squares witnessing and
since semifinal programming can be
solved using computers
I'm hiding some technical stuff under
the rank but uh you can use a computer
to help you find your sum of squats
sure
sure uh
like algebra
and it was developed by Sasha rasborg
all right any further questions
yes I'll bring you the microphones
thank you
um so uh in the early part of the talk
just rest it into the case L equal to 2
you mentioned that K4 and k1c are the
smallest non-common graphs and there's
also a result saying that any graph
containing a K4
is not common so do you expect or maybe
there's a counter example saying any
graph container K13 is not common
graph containing any H containing a K13
is also not common
it's
I mean once you not contain K13 then the
degree is bounded right I mean
even like if you tell me that there is
no K13
doesn't it mean that basically your
maximum degree is two ah I see it's
severely a sixth class of graphs I see
thank you
thank you any final question
no not then let's thank young again for
a wonderful
[Applause]
okay